- Honey,
I'm gonna give these Buzzfeed
gays everything they want.
(swooshing)
- Hello there, I'm Erika Jayne.
We're here at BuzzFeed and I'm gonna read
a few of your tweets.
Listening to how many
fucks by Erika Jayne.
Wig upgraded to a category five.
Is there any other compliment other than
"wig upgraded to a category five?"
I mean, thank you baby,
this is really sweet.
I'm gonna upgrade my
wig on account of you.
Oh, thank you.
Erika Jayne had all the
girls shook with the fashion
and now they're all
stepping their shit up.
Thank you, and I'll tell you why.
Number one we're on television,
and number two it says
the word Beverly Hills.
With that kind of name in the title,
you gotta bring it.
Ooo, this looks like a beefy one.
Kinda like you.
When you're so broke you
literally had a jar you're using
to save all your change in order to buy
@erikajayne's new book so I
can binge read the first day.
Pretty mess, I'm a pretty mess.
David, I used to save change too, baby,
in this city of New York,
so I'm here to tell you
that if it can happen for me,
it can fucking happen for you.
If there is a heaven or hell,
may Erika Jayne's gay Glam
Squad be waiting at the gates
to make me look sickening for it.
Baby lemme tell ya, we
ain't going to Heaven,
we going on an express
train to Hell in my crew.
Yes, Cassandra, I agree.
And they are lovely, and
we do need to look good.
Petitioning Fordham to
add @erikajayne's new book
to the list of required
reading for incoming freshmen.
You get this and I'm coming to lecture,
and I need one of those pretend degrees
'cause I didn't go to college.
@erikajayne, girl I
showed my boyfriend you
and you are definitely his new crush.
I can't not believe you're
in your 40's and look to hot.
Hot bod, hot hair, hot clothes,
hot makeup and hot dance moves.
I need a Glam Squad to get
my hair going like yours.
Love you Erika!
You can always be
fabulous, do not let anyone
dictate when you're done
or anything like that.
Age is bullshit.
Keep it pushing.
Alright, come on.
When you blow your knee
out doing the drop split
to Erika Jayne's xxpen$ive ouch.
Baby, lemme tell ya I blew out my knee
doing the drop split to
Erika Jayne's xxpen$ive
more than once which
is why when I get home
from this tour, I've got
to go see my surgeon again
for the third time, so
don't you worry honey,
it's fine, it's okay Skyler.
Could you send me a video?
Erika Jayne has great wigs.
I've only seen her tracks
one time all season.
Okay, here's the thing babes.
Not wigs, bonds, so like it's all in here,
but thank you baby for
noticing 'cause this hairstyle,
well this hair, is like a lifestyle.
I mean, it's a lot of
money and a lot of upkeep
so thanks for noticing.
Can't wait for Erika Jayne
to release new music.
Literally queen of dance and the gays.
Thanks baby, I appreciate that.
New music is on the way
and I hope you like it
because that's the point,
you're supposed to dance
and have a good time and feel good.
Alright, are we done?
Oh my God, thank you, BuzzFeed!
I'm Erika Jayne, thank you so much.
Remember, have a good time,
and thank you for having me, Buzzfeed.
Enjoy.
(upbeat pop music)
(swooping)